I'm intrigued when did your personal
journaling practice start Ray or it's
about 25 years ago I started when I
started building my company I it was a
point of having 67 people I remember it
because every holiday season I would you
know I started my company from nothing
so I had two people four people well
okay we got up to 67. I remember it was
67 because it was holiday season and
every holiday I would
um shop for their individual gifts and
I'd write each individual long notes and
That Was Then long enough take took me
long enough to realize that I really
need to communicate better with them um
I also journaled because I needed to
write down my decision rules for the
markets so that I could go back test
them
so I it's a very great power if you can
know what your criteria would be and
then say how could I how would they have
worked in the past how would they worked
in this country or that country because
then you're not just making decisions
you have perspective on making the
decisions so those two things together
got me into journaling